and that is of course a crazy
driver in our direction now that
people are now dealing with energy prices
and energy consumption
that was
not the case seven eight years ago
when you walked across the street
and asked people e.g. how much
do you give to the  Year for your heating costs,
no one could tell you or
what brand your heating system is,
no one can say
even a question with which
energy supplier you are, um, people ca
n't answer that correctly, ne
if you now think in the automotive sector
what brand is your car
everyone knows that immediately, so that means it's a
is a segment was
actually in the
dark somewhere in the basement people did
n't really
sit down together, but it's just so incredibly
important because a third of the world's
energy is used for it, so
more  as e.g. in the entire transport sector,
that means if we want to create the energy transition
then we have to address this this this
heat market this
heat segment everyone is talking
about energy these days and how you
should heat your house and apartment today and in the future and what is
all that  could cost and what
options there are options and we do
that too with you the knowledge
must when I go with the founder of tado
and his name is Christian Dahlmann
welcome from tado the
founder Christian hi moin so you are
the energy expert so to speak  all of a sudden,
not all at once, but
for many years, no, well, I've
always been
interested in energy issues and that's why I
started studying in the field,
so I studied mechanical engineering management
with a focus on
environmentally friendly energy systems and
I've always dealt with this topic there
and that's how
it was two
decades ago, so in 2002 I got
started, so to speak, at the beginning I
researched fuel cells and
in 2003 I had my first professional experience at
SFC energy. Back then it was
a startup in Munich that
built fuel cells and later
Going public was a very
formative time and I think
that’s when I caught a bit of fire
for this topic of energy and
also with interpreenurship, so
to brew companies around in the system
I just caught there before and
then you’re still there too  to say about
this super
elite university that uh went to the USA
with. It is
probably the most important
school in the world for engineers or something like that, how
important it is in any case and that then
refines your knowledge about energy again  Yes, exactly, I
did my student exchange in Massachusetts, near Boston, and then
of course we
went there to do handicrafts more often at the weekend and I've
always been so interested in technical
topics, I always
walked around this university that
I wanted to be there  I went there at some point and
then he first
started studying in Munich and always
looked at how how how can I actually
get into the Internet MRT and
somehow that never worked out and when
I finished my studies in
Munich then I had it  Acceptance and
then I thought crap and such an ambition
I'm ready the flowers and
erm now I have the acceptance and I
said come on then I'll
just add a master's degree I'll treat
myself to two more there and it was
mega  cool time I just worked there on
erm on wind turbines so
in life elements like these
the red leaves are ideally designed so that
they become even more energy efficient
but after that you then I
saw it that way relatively normally first
became a consultant and not at all into the
energy sector are
right right so the idea for tado
actually came about um there um 2008
um MRT here we
wrote in um reset paper about
energy flows in the world where we
generate energy where we now consume
it is transported and um that's what
I noticed  that about 1/3 of the world
more energy is used for heating and air conditioning
of buildings and um
[music]
I'll say it now, I lived there in
a shared flat with an air conditioning system
and it ran relatively inefficiently and there are
always discussions with our
roommates  How do we actually
get our electricity bill down and
that’s how tado came up with the idea
that we actually
have to digitize it and that when we
’re out and about during the day
the air conditioning at home doesn’t work, so
we were a flat share of five people at the time
and  um the air conditioning ran
all day long so it's
kind of cool when we
come back in the evening but of course that does
n't make much sense and that's how
these ideas are actually hey
you can't control it from your cell phone
you can't
control it automatically  when you leave the
house that the air conditioning
goes out the heating keeps coming back that
is preheated before it cools
and uhm yes I had discussed that
with Johannes Schwarz and our
co-founders at the time and we
actually wanted to tackle it but it was
n’t like that yet  It was the right time
to found a company and that’s why
I want to be in Germany in general,
no, not for us. It was
actually such a personal decision
that we said
I had
a small company with Johannes during my studies and it
worked out really well  but somehow
we thought we had to
start normal jobs first and Johannes
then became a patent attorney and I
started at a venture capital company at Target partners in
Munich and um also with the aim of investing
more in companies in the energy sector there,
after that
you can  beraterstation ne that was before that
i worked at etikani for a year and a half
right then but from
this whole world, let's say
entrepreneurship is somehow seen from the outside
so invest in it or fry
you then decided okay now i'm doing
what i've
always dreamed of exactly
Exactly, we've been
dreaming of it for a long time, so to speak, and
then
Johannes Schwarz and I, um,
continued to work on the concept parallel to our jobs, so
we developed prototypes that
we installed at home with family
and friends, um
Written business plan
at the end would not now know how it
works if you have a heater at home
and then you turn this device
with which you actually adjust the heating
this little wheel you turn off
and instead you put a device of
yours on it so that takes it  you
can control the thermostat and this device,
um, remotely, and that can
then also automatically measure the room temperature
and then adjust the heating, so to speak,
and so you have a dynamic, so to speak,
and you don’t even go there in the
morning and turn the heating on
again in the evening  and that
has a much more dynamic neck
control, even from a distance
and as such features are absolutely
right, so we have
products
for all houses and apartments to
control heating air conditioning and a
product of this is this
radiator thermostat exactly what  as
described, that you
turn on the radiator directly, so to speak, and
this is then connected to the Internet
with the tado app and
thus a lot of
intelligence comes into the control so
that, for example, when you get out of
the in the morning  the house is that a
lowering mode is then switched on when you
come back it is already preheated,
e.g. if someone opens the window,
the heating goes off and the normal
thermostat also goes full throttle, so it heats
with full force out of the window.
You can also do this in the app, for
example  so also set schedules
so that you say yes that
I only want to heat the hobby room at the weekend or
here I do it at night during the day so etc.
the bathroom may only have to
be really warm to 23 degrees with two and a half hours in the morning or after that
19 degrees or something is enough  that means
you can also use such schedules
because that’s even more intelligent or
that
’s our core product exactly these
different controls for heating and
air conditioning thermostats and everything
connected with the tado app that
’s our camera a bit I have
in the  Read through a few test reports beforehand
and tried to
understand that because I haven’t erm at home yet,
that means it’s so easy in
assembly that you kind of
just order things, so to
speak, sometimes from Amazon or
from you and then, um, you can do it yourself
just do it at home without tools because
turn off the normal heating controller and
put yours on it and then you get
it yourself also connected to the internet so
I don't know a bit why because
I understand WiFi at home and
then you close the app via his
on his  Cell phone on and then understands what
that and it is a bit to
do by giving some test reports this
is very chic or looks
like a very old slim part so
looks a bit cooler than this
thick one always knows
and how much does it cost  So if you
buy it then I think it costs 70 or
90 but variant exactly with 69 € per
radiator now in the case and
if you also connect the heating system
then, so to speak, the
heating unit in the basement is
about 150 euros on top of it once  once
and then there are monthly subscription
costs if you want to be able to do something special,
we
have that in the app, we have a Premium
Premium variant, which means that it is
basically free of charge and
you can also use it with the core app  already
you can do a lot of good things
and if you then
want to use the premium functionalities of tado
then it costs 3 € a month it's
below it runs under places it's
called our our premium subscription
you can then do that in the  Book an app
and then things like
presence detection will be
completely open detection and so on
automated for the customer, so from the point of view of the
managing director, it’s
a bit like pilleton and buys
hardware, but then it’s also part of
a subscription or there’s one too
other examples of coffee capsules
used to be the very famous
examples of coffee machines and I
keep buying the capsules, so it’s a big
investment at the beginning, so not
just a few hundred euros, like less than €100
to start with, and then you’re in for a subscription,
um, toni is still there  just one
example of these figures and
then you always get new new
content, so there you are in
this game hardware and then a
software but on the back exactly
that is uh, as I said premium concept
the free version is really good
so to be honest it is better than any
other smartphone thermostat that you
can buy otherwise, but we have
invested a lot of energy and time in order to
develop the additional function, this
additional function,
we calculate this monthly
fee, which
you can add to your account  cancel or
re-book so for of your
customers have this subscription exactly the so
places assist is called this our
oldest product there it is used by 25% of
our customers who
pay for it and then we have had
another subscription since last summer
that is called  tado Balance
and that’s for heat pump customers and
erm
with it the
heat pump can be controlled even more intelligently,
which means that it runs faster, especially
in times when energy is cheap,
and fills the hot water tank, e.g.
fills the buffer tank  etc.
so that the times during the day when
energy prices are particularly expensive
that they can be bypassed.
This works primarily with the
dynamic energy tariffs, i.e.
hourly energy tariffs, and for
this function that these loads
are shifted from this heat pump
to the favorable times, we calculate
for  an air heat pump 4 euros a month
and for a water heat pump 10 euros a
month okay and how many of these
devices are there now so the
whole thing started already so the
company the company was founded in the early
10s ne exactly we
founded in September 2011 so that  means you've been
on the road for quite a while now so for a salad that's 12
years old it's no longer a salad that's been
around for 12 years is already
a word at the time how many
of the thermostats we've sold uhm
well over  3 million are
sold in Europe are the market leaders in
our in our segment are active in all
European countries, so
we also make 75% of our sales outside
of Germany,
so there are then important players in these segments
and it will then be
an annual turnover of what
magnitude
there  are we
runright moderately now in so in one way
we are heading in the three-digit
range okay that means runright
maybe in the year 24 then 100 million
is realistic so
we don't talk about numbers but in 23 we will be well over well over
well over the
100 million okay okay  that's
really a word that
really lights up yes um how many people
work for you we are about 200
employees mainly in Munich
then also in the office in
London and um a company in Vienna
bought a good year that also means
a location  Vienna and
is that, let's say in terms of
technical innovation, something very
special, what you're doing there, now as a
loaner, you think to yourself, okay, they have
a thermometer there, somehow, that the
room temperature is that he recognizes when
it gets colder, open the window and then
I somehow control the heating with the
power I would do with my normal hand
and yes you can
somehow control it from afar
you can do that with many
things on the internet so I could now well
first of all as I okay logical
that  there's something like that now it's not that
crazy crazy technically
it doesn't seem like
autonomous driving to me or no idea so
quite a layman but I get it so
I'll say I just
told you
that I did a lot of research on fuel cells at the beginning
I did research on wind turbines and
noticed there that innovation there
just takes decades to
come onto the market and, um, because I
'm just driven to have an impact in the
direction of an
environmentally friendly energy supply,
we have Johannes schwarz and
of course, um, and I have an  Topic
picked out what you
can also bring to the market faster but can then also
develop further so this this
basic idea I connect a heater
and uh regulates intelligently from the from
the
Internet that you can
basically implement
within a few years, we then
noticed  that it is significantly more complex
because also technologically because there are
over 900 relevant manufacturers of
heating systems and
in most cases you have to bring the system in the
basement with you online and
each of these 900 manufacturers has
different protocols how to do it
you control them and we had to
develop everything as a company and
right now we are the only
cross-manufacturer platform
there that can, erm, connect all these systems from all these
manufacturers
and is compatible with them
and that was pretty
tough, we have something like that  said it was
used for quite a while and
erm we are now faced with
a huge market, so in Europe
private households spend
300 billion euros a year for heating and air
conditioning their buildings and
he says you can
save 30% with your tool  so if you now save 22%
okay yes that means of these 30
billion you said 300 billion
euros will be for energy for heating
air-conditioning buildings 300 billion
so the 20% would save then 60 years
right uh that's words exactly
but the penetration  now with 3
million devices it's still in the
range of I don't know um 0 or yes
well that's um the market is um
is still there is still growing so and
there um it's also very different
um country so e.g. in the Netherlands
25% of all households have such
products installed smart thermostats
to control their heating
in England it's like the UK is like seven
eight percent and in the other
European countries we're less than
five
percent that and the product category
is just pretty new so
when we started  a good ten
years ago we were when we were the only
company in this area to bring heating to the
internet, many
immediately declared us to be a bit crazy
and now it's getting
stronger and stronger, yes, that was the last war
for you  also
probably an accelerator,
yes, above all, the high energy prices
that were triggered by the energy crisis
were exactly those
massive accelerators, so last
year we also grew more than 100% in
sales and we weren’t able to drive all our
sales and marketing activities
as intensively as
otherwise just to
reach these customers because basically all of
Europe was talking about energy prices and
energy efficiency and that
is of course a crazy driver
in our direction now that people are
now dealing with energy prices and
energy consumption that
was seven eight years ago  it wasn't like that
when you crossed the street
and asked people, e.g.
how much you get for your
heating costs per year, no one could tell you
or what brand your
heating system is, no one can
tell
even a question about which energy
supplier  Are you, people ca
n't answer that correctly when you
think about what
brand your car is in the automotive sector, everyone knows
that straight away, so that means it's one is
a segment that
used to be a bit hidden
somewhere in the basement, people did
n't have it  not really
dealt with, but it is just so
incredibly important because
a third of the energy worldwide
is used for this, more than, for example, in the
entire transport sector, which means if
we want to achieve the energy transition
then we have to address this this
this this heat market this heat segment
and  this has really come about now
because of this energy crisis
from wallpaper and um people are
talking about it and looking for a solution on how to
optimize the energy they spend at home, which is so completely new or
so unique in that sense to me that's why it's
not um if the preparation
because it already existed  sometimes this famous one for
my nest which then or the company is
not like that would then google which
bought it for billions a
few years ago it
caught my attention last year but
Toni for Dell who is invented
also invented it  here at the festival, even
if the iPhone was invented or a
very successful guy, Nest also
made
it comparable, or they
made the Google deal, so to speak, which
you would have liked to have made or how do
you see how do you get them,
well, we were us  we were there earlier than
as Nest so we were out earlier with
our products had
founded our company earlier but yeah um Toni
Verdell the iPhone with co-developer
then of course got off to a good start in the USA with nest
had collected um
many 100 million venture capital from the start
and has to  say the USA is
always a big, grateful market
to make the company
bigger even faster than in
Europe, but in Europe we are significantly
larger than Nest, that is, when they
came to England next,
that was the first year  country
that you discovered for Europe
we said okay we have to
be faster in the UK that's also one of the
reasons why we expanded so quickly
because we said we want to
close Europe here before Nest
and
then we were in before Nest  UK and are
now also bigger than Nest
in Europe, that means a
success story, I mean,
the deal was of course good for the
billions paid, it was a few
years ago in the hope that it
would really become the topic, but it is felt
now Nest, at least in Europe,
he says himself, but I also encounter it in the USA
when I'm
not that often, yes, they do it is
also in Google's annual report,
they make somewhere er something over a
billion in sales Nest that is  one that
means they are already of
a certain magnitude in the
Google group, of course, not big, but
what I actually promised Google back then
that Nest would build him
such an operating system for the home
a a smart home platform and
that has um  the Nest team didn’t put so much
on the street, they
then had a
second initiative within Google that was called
google home, where this Google home
speaker also came out at some point and
that’s actually their
smart home platform, that is, theirs  The
second internal development strand for
this topic was then faster than
the development strand at Nest and
so Nest is
now the hardware division within the Google company, which
produces and markets intelligent thermostats but also cameras, doorbells and such stories and in general
you can  good financing with the model
compared to others, i.e. the
Nest, but there are also if you
read the test reports like this, I
think Viessmann
also offers a traditional heating engineer
or, in the meantime, above all,
heat pumps, I believe, but
there are a whole series of 500  I
've never heard of them offering something like this in the end,
so then I imagine
a hardware game with a lot of competitors.
Even then, the pressure on margins is high  On
the subject of Viessmann, they
also sell our products, so
that happens there in a Cobra
branding, they also have their own products, um, there are
two tracks running with
our systems and with their own,
um, and in terms of the business model,
it’s about that for us, on the one hand, um,
first of all  to win the customers over
there was almost screwed to the heating systems
and
then over a long period of time, so
when our systems are installed,
the customers actually stay with us for an average of
18 years based on the types of
gymnastics we calculated
and the  over these 18 years we
then sell our customers further services, for
example the um three euro autistic subscription
that I just told you about
or our balance subscription of
10 € a month, then we bought the company Avatar from the
good years energy supplier
means
we now also sell
heat tariffs to our customers is a particularly
intelligent heat tariffs which,
together with our regulations,
ensure that the energy price
is cheaper because we
shift the loads to times when energy is currently cheap,
i.e. with ours  heat tariffs,
our our customers can
also lower their energy prices by another 15
to 20%,
the others, i.e. the competitors that
you can find, who also
offer this hardware, they
don’t all have it exactly, so we have a
very clear service strategy that  we
use our customer relationship, our customer satisfaction, and
use this and that data and
offer services over a long period of time, i.e.
digital software services and energy
services, for example
energy contracts, so what I’m talking about right now is
the model, so on the hardware
side you can see  differentiate then
you don't make any money but
you earn the money later with
the subscriptions with the software that's how it is, well
I'd say we also earn money with
the hardware too, we earn
money in all business areas but you
're right of course if  we would now only
sell the hardware and um that's that
's not exciting
enough yes are they the um that the margins
are gone from the business model also over the lifetime of the um the customer is that um that's not
exciting enough that  That means it's
really about
adding services to these customer relationships and
then developing them further and we
're in this
heat management area right now and
we're the market leader and we're still the
only ones who have digital services, for example,
who do that  Energy
Services combine that's what
none of our competitors do and
now, through the acquisition of
Avatar, we now also offer
PV feed-in tariffs, for example, and
charging management solutions
for electric cars that's all still on a
smaller scale is a few
thousands of customers that Avatar
has connected and managed there, but
in the long term we want to move from this
heat management platform to an
energy management platform for the building,
which means that in addition to the heat area, we
also want to take the areas of Evie charging and PV
management with us okay, um, but
the company for them isn’t there yet  More money,
more losses, we are
now ahem close to profitability, so
this year will be our first
profitable year
and that is
precisely what happened
last year, just really
great because we
were able to benefit from the high energy prices, we
were able to really outgrow our costs
that we
still saw massive growth spurts
last year with lower costs and now
also in one in the first part of this with
this year that means we see
the trend progressing and where do
the customers come from that means
people just google to save energy
and then you bought the keywords there
or did you then somehow get
good search results and then or or
how do they find you as an example,
of course we also work via marketing
via online marketing, but we are also, um,
in many
stores, e.g. in all Apple stores
Europe-wide the partner for Apple
in the field of heat management was still the one
that
was compatible with the homekit platform, then of
course a wide variety of retail retailers
that you know, we also work with
other energy suppliers, so
we now work with
12 of the 20 largest energy suppliers
in Europe  where we put together
bundle offers that
energy tariffs are sold there together with our
heat management solutions
or the OEMs mentioned, such as
Viessmann, which you just
mentioned, so these are our
ways to the market
and we are currently building
another one  market segment and that is
the housing industry that we go to
larger
managers or owners of
real estate portfolios, for example
vonovia or THG and they
convince them to install an
intelligent, more
efficient heat management system for their tenants
say okay we'll do it and then you'll have
a few thousand devices right away, so of
course those are big
multipliers exactly, and
tell me you
tried to bring the company to the stock market last year
yes, right, that's the idea
at least yes, we're planning to
consider that  it was actually
almost Anhalt a good one and a half years
old
when we are
originally we were asked
if we should do such an IPO together with number the number 2 from the USA
so that was also about
a about a SPECT back then
that was the the  company ecobi, so to speak,
next to Nest, the second big
player in the USA,
but somehow as part
of this process, they then
sold their company to
another Canadian company and, to be
honest, the
year before last we were very, very much
such specs so
we came to the team of uh Josef Brunner
and Gisbert Rühe
I believe also as industry manager
at Klöckner so at this in
Duisburg at this steel manufacturer or something like that
was exactly exactly a great team and
they asked us if we
didn't want to do it with them,
they put on such a mountain and that's when
we noticed that there's just
a super great match between
us and they also shared the visions
they had for the company
very much with our vision then
in December 21
we then
signed an elui that we would just put the
company on the stock exchange together,
then created pitches with banks with
JP Morgan and um bernberg
and then wanted to then
um even have to place under pipe are
then middle  February went out to
place the capital market and um that
was about the same
time as the Ukraine war
started four weeks earlier, there was
this interest rate shock that interest rates
went up, technology companies
were also affected, so that means
that
the capital market
started last  year was simply
not open
to new technology topics and even with
these Diespeck transactions there is
still a redemption rate, which
means that the investors who invested there
can
decide again whether they really
want to stay with us or not and we have
seen that in the USA at the time there were
98 percent redemption rates, which means
the money in the spark was 150 million at the time
if 98% of it is
withdrawn then there is in
fact somehow not anything left
and um yeah then that was us
overall  just a bit too hot
yes that we said everyone the market
is not ready for it right now there are
these high redemption rates at the
same time our business is going
incredibly well and could not have gone better
and to be honest we wanted to get involved
in such a capital market
don't don't get under the wheels there
was even a rating so
if you talked about
half a billion as a film rating or that's
exactly what we had
agreed and it was even if
this if the
Ukraine war hadn't come it would have worked
one hundred percent  yes and then
that would also be a really good one for you
or for you so think about it now
somehow over 100 million sales and
at that time the rating was I would say only
half a billion now you have
the topic of the hour energy now a
maltepel of five in that  Growth in
sales then seems almost
small to me, so you're probably
Unicorn, yes, exactly, so, all in
all, it was a super exciting time
and now in the
end, as you say, actually
even better for the company we have
then  now at the beginning of this other one
we have again taken up a small or a
financing round of 43 million euros
a small one is good but
in the ratio between 50 exactly
um
and overall we are now super well
positioned 43 million round
we don’t disclose that but also in  the
size is alright yes ok so they
came in comparatively cheap would say the last
investors absolutely yes exactly and um Jeff
Bezos or Amazon at least you can
read about it also invested in yes
exactly they came in with us a few years ago
um how came
So you just called, here
is Amazon, or yes, when you wanted to
bring Alexa to Europe, uh,
you needed this language assistant, so you needed
someone to help him
to make the products compatible for Europe
and also needed customers who
were there for him  At that time it was still in a
beta phase and they asked us
whether they could use our customers for this
and then we
asked our customers under NDA and yes,
we then built a very close
relationship with Amazon and then
they did at some point  asked if they
could also invest in our company and then we took them on as part
of a round of financing
and it's also really exciting,
so what do we have to go into it with you
or something that's just, um,
not a huge amount now  At that time
a 50 million round of financing was
already a decent round and
Amazon made an entry of how
much money is actually a total of around
150 million. It's also
from the fun racing because he's gotten
used to it a bit over the last year but still is  Yes, it's
still a really big number, so
collecting 150 million is quite an
achievement,
well, I'll say we have a super
strong team that built a super company,
or we all together and
so we can of course also
convince investors to continue the journey
together  to do because the
financiers are above all let's
say German companies isn't these
American blood chips that's
also summer some capital about which I did
n't say at all ne so the
specialists then for the for the
energy sector yes now mainly
in the
last round mainly
invested so-called impact force,
for example Trill impact as the song
investor from this from this round these
are large private equivor from Sweden
founded by Jan Stahlberg who
founded the company a few years ago and
he was also the founder of EQT  also
a large private equity company and has
now launched its own impact form,
has um
1.3 billion
under management and
you just joined us with the fund
and a few other
companies from this
impact area  well that's that's that's that's the
investors with whom we
mainly work because
that's a problem for you if now so
the I read recently that the
worker said he wants to
get rid of oil and gas heating is that
good or bad for you  that's great
because, first of all, because we're
passionate about it and making the world renewable,
and um, secondly, of course,
the heat pump gets
more impetus and with a
heat pump we can
add value through digitalization,
so with a normal gas oil
heating system we can do that
Optimizing efficiency how much energy
it consumes by taking account of presence and
absence schedules
integrating weather forecasts
taking into account open windows and now with
the heat pump we can also participate in the
energy market that we say
we load
hot water tanks buffer tanks when
energy is cheap and we
just unload them  In times when
energy is currently expensive, that means we
can increase the added value for the customer again
and it is not as if
other companies will soon also be involved in the
business that you are doing,
so let's introduce
companies that produce heat pumps or
is also  Philipp Schröder of 1.5
degrees was Christian here, um, so
people who want to control the entire house
somehow, so to speak, bring the
largest hardware equipment, so to speak,
it's not easy for them,
I'll say hard, spun
feature what you offer and then
say  we are now doing that directly
and then you are no longer what
you are perhaps even superfluous
so the technology platform that you
have to build behind it and that we have been
building for about twelve years
is that that is not to be
underestimated so our goal  is then
exactly to work with these players,
whether it
is Philipp Schröder or Mario from
endpal or Philipp from
thermondo
with some of them we
already work together
and are there, um,
technology platform for,
but now also in  As part of our
further development, we want to
further incentivize these partnerships there,
because I believe or
we believe that
just setting up such an operations company,
hiring installers,
selling systems that we
install, etc. is in itself
a huge, huge task  and
having the right child and that means
he now says I can
set up a new technology company in-house at the same time,
so I think that we
are in a much better position in terms of perspective, that we can
then offer the technology platform white label to
such providers  what we are
already doing today
and
that we are working there through partnerships
then in the end the the overall market
it would have to be a bit
anyway if we look at it or something like that
then I also thought it when I
thought in the research okay um then
you do for  the technology and they make
the hardware, but if you
look at the rating,
you are rated worse and worse as a technology,
so now I don't know a factor of
five or six, and sometimes
I'm hearing something like unicorn from exactly 1.5 degrees
end 2 billion
valuation so that means there is still
a lot more fantasy somehow although they
supposedly do the easy business in the
end
I am of the opinion that in
this technology platform if you
really build this platform there
and there is there there is  Yes,
there are network effects on the
heating side, as I said, there are more than
900 relevant manufacturers in Europe
who all have their different
protocols and interfaces. If
I now also
want to charge an electric car on the charging side, I have to
develop an integration cooperation with each manufacturer  because I have to
know exactly how full
the car is now being charged and um the
charging process has to be able to stop aisles in the states
etc and similarly also on the
PV side, which means I have
many, many hundreds or thousands of um
manufacturers who deal with the the  which has to be made
compatible with my platform
and um that's a huge one that's a
really big board and um we're
now in the warm area we've
made all the compatibility
perspective practical if you have even more
market power you can of course turn the game
around that  the one that
says we have many
millions of users and customers and for the
OEMs of heating systems, heat pumps,
electric cars, etc., it is interesting
to integrate into this platform and
make it compatible with
it, similar to an Apple homekit,
for example, or a  Google home has managed
to
turn this integration logic over the market and um
that means that in the end from my
point of view there
will actually be three four players on this platform side and no
longer and um the one who there this this this this
this platform  In
my opinion, positioning will have a very strong
positioning and thus also evaluation.
Recently, Katrin Suder was the
digital expert here and also a cyber security
connoisseur.
She told me a little bit about
everything that is possible
hacking and
breaking into systems somewhere so far it was
relatively difficult with the heating,
now if you bring the heating all together as a network,
it has happened
that people suddenly
adjust the temperatures or that
you suddenly have someone there because
can manipulate the heating at home no,
it has never happened before and we
also have an incredibly good
team of developers who are also
very important for this topic for us
as management, of course, but also for our
employees themselves,
some come from the  Chaos Computer
Club that means they
also deal with it in their free time and in the
end how we realize it all our
devices have an IP address and
the same
encryption methods that are
used in online banking are running there and they
are continuously updated so that
we  Ultimately, our system is as secure
as online banking, but
of course we have to work on it, it
remains secure and we do that so that it can
somehow continue in the future because nothing, uh,
no hacking attacks can happen,
which still belong to the company
Order of magnitude 8% or something like that so
these are also numbers that we do
n't not publish you can research it a
little yes you can
do it yes you won't you do
n't want to say it I'm on the
wrong track but you don't
want to confirm yes exactly you  can do the
research you're right there,
so why do you have to be ashamed, I
mean, when it's going to be a billion-dollar
company and you still
somehow hold 8%.  that's gigantic yes yes or
I mean
that would be uncomfortable no no it's
just um we've never talked about numbers like that before
but you
're right of course you
can look up a lot in the commercial register
so that means but going public is still a thing
Topic when the
capital markets are back up and
there is a bit more calm
and the other has been successful
then I would probably be
able to introduce you again but
to add more normally yes so basically
we find it exciting about the
company I’ll say more now or
to set it up less for eternity and then not to get involved in such
sales processes,
that's why we actually find the IPO
to be a very exciting
story for tado and but yes, as
you said, we have to for the
next few years, we have to now
First of all, scale the company again
properly, continue to
grow somehow around the 100% growth that is now expanding
our business model on a profitable level,
as just discussed,
that we should sell more energy contracts to
our customers via the Avatar
acquisition, then continue into charging
PV  Management, the whole thing also for the
housing industry, that means we have
a lot ahead of us, but
unfortunately I'm on other
topics right now, so I'm a little
closer to passing on energy here,
that would be a
position and to prepare, but
one thing that I then also  not clear
but for example now he arrives like
endpal yes mario was also here
a few weeks ago and they
already want to make billions in sales I
think he said several billions in
sales and they haven't been around
that long, they're
doing it  Call center and
really actively go into the market and and
at the end we take the word because
their systems into the market why ca
n't you do that so why don't you go
so why not go with a
cheaper product if there's totally clear
because the preposition which  That's right, I do
n't understand, uh, I don't even get
a billion sales any faster,
why are you now, after so
many years, only at
around 100 million,
exactly? I think that's important
when you
look at the customer numbers, for example, from the
companies mentioned in comparison to us, then of
course I don’t know the exact numbers,
but in any case we
probably have 70 or 80 times more
customers than we have, that means
our our product is
scalable faster, you can
reach more customers faster, but we
obviously earn a lot less per second
if I sell a solar system and a
heat pump then maybe I’ll sell
a system for somewhere around
80,000 euros that’s of course a lot more
than if I somehow put
radiator thermostats on the
heating for someone for 70 euros Turner obviously is a
big one  Factor in between um, that
means for us it's a um, it's a
scaling game that on the
one hand we scale our customers
and then bring the customer value
customer lifetime value, so what
we already have is this
incredibly long customer live time  from
18 years that means if you look at this
whole country exactly but uhm there are
calculation methods how you look at the from the
types of gymnastics if we now
have more than eleven years of course from the
different cohorts that the chanrates
and there are calculation methods around
these these  to calculate these avage lifetimes
and you can also
imagine that if you have just screwed such a
system to the heating system
you get about the you have gotten
used to the app you get an
energy saving report every month how much
energy how many euros do I have
saved this month because tado
is installed
so if I'm satisfied with the product
what our customers are which you can also
see from all the reviews why
should I go and
take it down again
to write something else again that means I then have
a real sticking  is
because it is screwed but that
means I have these 18 years and
these 18 years, I have to pay
the monthly fees via the digital service,
but also the
energy services, so in the
energy contracts I have to
earn a little money from the customer from the customer  take a
more aggressive approach, what did
you just say about the
partnerships with the
housing industry or
similar apartments and the Apple Store are you also
there because it is also a very
aesthetic product, but there are
n't any other influencers who are suddenly
somehow there in their story
turn off their heating thermostats and turn on new ones
and something like that does
n't exist or don't you make any
sense yes but so there's also um so it
was even with influenza that's
of course for in our
product category a little
fewer and fewer than inside was
knossi back then or I don't know  somehow
go to the Gercke and grow something like that, yes,
that's true, but that's um, let me tell you,
our target group are
primarily, um,
people who have a family house, for example, or
at least, um, well,
I'll say from 30 onwards, that is,
they  um the younger people you have
other topics I think I still have in mind yes
okay okay
again something what so save money in the end
and the environment especially so the two
big currents
are also going to be listened to by people in their 20s
now that’s not the
case either  a lot of money about that now someone
with 25 not somehow exactly euros for that
you already have that basically
right is basically right yes no
exactly but we are also um under
full pressure and
if you still have ideas for further
influenza exchange totally on everything
give
or do you have to be interested in everything
I make of my fashion
influencer just like a car
Influenza suddenly they come with it
aesthetically chic thermostat on
screws that on if it’s as
easy as you are yes and then like
I’d bet that people  also want to
say hey look that's exactly that's it
in the end it's
also our task to bring this
product from the from the
in the group to the mass market
but I think we're
in the earlier  Mass market, so
in the early early majority, as they
say in English, and so
we have to push it through
this
life cycle of the
product launch process more and more
until we finally
arrive at the complete dimensions
and at the end with the shopping cart
or with the merchandise body plus
durability so that’s the way the last
customer works,
you can finance everything possible,
so if it’s
so worthwhile at the end of the day, uh, then you have
marketing up front, so customer acquisition
costs result from it and then
when are they profitable  Customers
can shop there, you ca
n't do sports spons everywhere and think about the really big
things because who has customers for 18
years? Durability with a high degree
because if you've always activated the subscription
then it does
n't puke so much anymore, so
put someone there  I've always
wondered when and when do you go there and make
the really big marketing splashes, it
has to be budgeted somehow in the end,
so just a moment if you
want to be successful and somehow
make a billion sales or
something like that, then yes, it has to be  Being like that is
no different than when
people in Germany at least
know tado and you also have this
tattoo thing and then they say yes, I
also have a tattoo yes yes that is
the journey that has to be made or yes
exactly  the next stadium has
to be called that or somehow have no
idea yes somehow it would have to
get in your face wide yes exactly I mean that is of course um
with such
marketing investments
you always have to
take a close look at which ones then
pay off, we have had quite a performance there
up-to-date we've
already
started campaigns at ProSieben um and um but I've
seen that the
customer acquisition costs right now, for
example through these
mass market advertising media,
are actually a bit too expensive, so
if you're out and about in certain
other media there, for
example TV advertising works
then, for example, he's good on these
N24 channels NTV or Discovery Channel
or Servus TV, these are e.g. the in
the television channels that
works well for us in terms of advertising
ProSieben, for example, or Sat.1 was
actually much too expensive from the customer acquisition costs, but that's
of course possible  of the time here um the
better known the product category becomes the
more you are with the
product category mass market then
these
mass media also work better
alright so we will observe how
he
continues to make the journey to the mass market
to the term and to the solution on  In
the end it really makes sense, so I
think from a line perspective
it seems to me to be an instrument with
which you can save money that
makes perfect sense and where you can then, above all,
simply reduce energy
or reduce emissions in the end
and what you can  in any case are so
if so
make sure he steps on the gas yes so you
say
good luck
thank you for coming thank you all right
ciao ciao ciao
[music]